hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to let's play the
witches house as you can see I'm finally
back in Cincinnati so get ready for more
videos coming at you because I'm finally
able to do straight recording okay
somebody said that I aim to pick up
these pedals here white petals are
scattered on the ground and I need to
take them for some reason and then there
was something to do with this darkroom
here that I need to go and do and wait
can I do anything in here
okay maybe not all right so I still need
to look around and see what's going on
here I've been here wasn't there
something damn what am I doing with the
flower petals in the empty bottle that
is the question I have no idea because
I'm a stupid idiot who can't figure out
anything on his own
okay so anyway we just solved the
mystery of oh oh oh yes yes can I help
you Oh No thank you please go away
there's something over here there's gas
noxious gas which I'm assuming would
kill me oh my god the timer's still
there I thought it was all gone
nevermind
I'm an idiot again so I have flower
petals I have something else I need to
give was this hidden in the darkness oh
damn it okay so I can't give these put
petals in a foot petals in a bottle okay
goody goody goody gumdrops why did I do
that
oh damn okay so I don't need to do with
a with that no birds in the birdcage
card nothing in there no one on the
chair hmm
ooh here we go what is this tadpole my
dad is dead yeah sorry about that
nose nose my bad that was my bad oh I'll
readily admit those my dad was eating my
snake huh ah nah that's not fair that's
not fair
what the hell yeah I killed him
I suppose it is fair in a cosmic sort of
way but not fair at all to me okay maybe
I got to put these flower petals in this
bottle and then drink it with nothing
ooh I gotta put what's the sack how did
I do that
I don't know Saba stop doing that okay I
got it
no brew right I'm such a baby
okay here we go all right got this put
that put it in the bottle put it in the
bottle all right put that in there go up
here and I'm guessing I need to get pat
holes in the bottle to hear about their
tab holes no okay
maybe just get some water from it it's
water fill with water yes what yes all
right
it begins emitting a light hey mr.
tadpole okay I'm not gonna bother you
anymore
cuz I don't want you to declare revenge
by dropping me into needing knee-deep
water need depth water I don't
understand how that killed me anyway
well they dragged me underground and
stir strangling me oh no I good I don't
like the place I don't like this place
at all this place is no good
whoo hello
Oh God hello hello hello
oh okay I'm okay
ha ha yo girl
alright I'm okay so nothing's gonna jump
out at me right nothing's gonna jump out
of me
the best course of action is to walk
recklessly into the darkness nothing
inside these dressers how about these
ones
nothing inside nothing inside ah take it
what I get a Jade pipe so I can smoke
some garlic
you weren't there before hi it got quiet
ha ha ha damn lit don't like these
vampire coffins hello it looks open ah
they're all headless they're all
headless no there you go
what's up here time is done over ok I
can't use any of those Oh
hmm
I did not like that place I blame it bad
little good god damn it
hello mr. t can't talk with me or did i
murder your friend alright alright you
got Jade Piper
whoopty-doo can i smoke those red grass
hi Edie I can't read you now apparently
so can i stuff some red I don't know
what I'm doing I've totally forgotten
why I would need why I would possibly
need a pipe is that giant skull still in
that room
if I go in here will I die hello mr.
skull
oh don't like that sound that's your
skull okay anyway there's nothing here
for me except for maybe a giant skull
waiting to stalk me but whatever I don't
care
I'm almost done here I guess I need to
find a reason to use this pipe they're
having a pleasant conversation say no
thank you
why'd you do that the vase fell over
good very good observational skills it's
not lit I don't want to go to bed
apparently do I have to go back
stop it stop doing these things to me
this two o'clock what about in here is
there something possibly in here all
right okay okay are anyway uh all right
I don't care I'm a safe have I saved I
don't think I saved okay so I need to go
back in here cuz the only place I
haven't been maybe just gone it it's got
it I died that's gonna happen so what do
i do i've got a jade pipe and nothing to
do with it maybe maybe there's some no
skull sills are already read that I've
already been through all these I don't
have anything besides the pipe and my
letter from the beginning I wonder if
there's gonna be some cosmic thing about
that letter in the beginning that I'll
need to know about but anyway I
obviously need to smoke something some
some money to smoke that would protect
me from the in acceptable my dad is dead
yeah yeah dad's died whatever okay here
we go no no lololo how wonderful ex that
frog is gonna come back to haunt me I
have no idea yeah
dammit ah come on I no idea what you
want from me game maybe I got a
backtrack a bit cuz obviously I can't go
forward any unless I'm missing something
horribly obvious ladies hello babies
whom hothea how you do I'm in a purple
dress can I stand on this can I get on
this okay apparently none hello
somebody here no no no I'm turning
hidden in the monster of the house okay
I really don't think that there's
anything here backtracking that I need
you did if anything I've already been
back here so there's not like there's
gonna be any extra jump scares for me
yep yep boys in the Hill home here yup
down here too ow
was later
ah I get that before didn't I I swear I
did I didn't probably oh man not an
idiot okay huh fine mister ah this is
the do this is hey mine is mine it's all
mine all right in here so now what
person van what up what what what
the making of payees panties pasties to
a sick child pairs dependents somewheres
you're too sloppy to make out Hey let
them bleed what with a headless little
girl or what was that was that a teddy
bear I don't know what that was
uh come on stop ahead won't you wear the
shoes okay if you say so
and after I hit it so well and what the
pipe I'm gonna go save jeez
hello mr. cat here let me tell you the
story about how I got trapped in this
horrible house and was stuck forever
okay do I need to wear the shoes shells
you don't know I'm
you told me a word up there goes my head
and my body just runs off with the shoes
ha ha ha
all right um oh hey ladies you want to
see my new shoes washes it's a real cool
trick and got y'all it I can live that
as they go tap dancing off into the
night Oh what do I do
maybe I gotta like wash him off ah ha ha
ha it's so smart I'm so smart can I wear
the Oh God tadpole [ __ ] you're trying
to murder me
I'll kill your whole family now son of a
[ __ ] where am I supposed to go with
that into the jail cell I guess or baby
I gotta go back and make another loop I
couldn't do anything no no I'm gonna
make a loop gonna make a loop gonna make
a loop gonna make it okay okay
everybody's we're good we're good bread
okay so I got special shoes this sign
said that I need to walk with clear
shoes so let's walk Oh Otto Otto walk on
poison la la la la la la la
ah I got distracted by my own body
falling from the ceiling knows I'm gonna
put this I don't need to put the shoes
on I'm just gonna walk straight through
the poison hopefully avoiding my
horrific knees
whew
all right all right all right all right
hang what's down here no wait a minute
what there was a choice ah did I make it
important choice I didn't X her because
she saved me from my sickness so I made
her my friend die about me yo what do
you suppose a friend is I don't know mr.
crap
what do you think a friend is ooh I
don't know okay anyway this is good
enough time to save it a people are
probably going no yours po you go here
are you way yeah I don't know I don't
know everybody I don't know this is why
created multiple save points are anyway
thank you all so much for watching click
the annotation for more videos that I've
done and as always I will see you in the
next video bye
ow
oh yeah
Oh